so a number of years ago people would
think of Elon as kind of uh green a
little bit left of center he was an
Obama supporter um and then over the
last number of years I think some people
think of him as actually kind of
conservative uh
reactionary um I have a sense that part
of that is because he's been attacked by
certain people and there's a natural
tendency that if you get attacked by a
certain group of people then you say
okay like I guess whoever doesn't like
you I guess I'm with them and I I I
personally uh you know see that as a
problem of
polarization um that there is this uh US
versus them left versus right Dynamic um
I I've been U frankly I think I've been
attacked by both
sides but um but what is your perception
as to um whether uh Elon uh actually
belongs that that conventional Left
Right Dynamic whether he's uh somewhat
uh independent uh or uh just like you
know intellectually not really um
ideological or easily categorized yeah
he's hard to characterize you're right
and in the book you'll see it in the
narrative the slow evolution of him
being what I would call him as a
traditional Center left you know
supporter of Obama supportive of
Democrats and he moves to a position
that's hard to put a label on but it's
basically I wouldn't say conservative
it's kind of populist right
pugnacious uh and sometimes they
believing in things I would call
conspiracy theories uh he doesn't spout
him too much but he lets him back on the
platform that used to be known as
Twitter and he'll retweet people or like
or say interesting or wow and so there's
part of that has moved to that area
partly it's a reaction to Democrats just
attacking him all the time and Elizabeth
Warren saying you know he doesn't pay
taxes what way should when he had in
fact that year paid more tax than any
other human has ever paid to any entity
in history uh and it's partly a personal
thing in the book which he felt that his
daughter became so infected by what he
called the woke virus that she hated
billionaires and hated capitalism and
changed her last name and wouldn't speak
to him and it's partly a reaction to I
think what he felt was too onerous of
shutdowns uh during coid so the
evolution in the book you see it happen
but as with everything
musque is not simple he's somewhat
Mercurial I can speak to him in the
middle of the day sometimes when I was
writing this book and he talked about
the need for moderates and having a
Centrist party having a pack supporting
people in the center and then sometimes
he'd be on just a you know a Jag about
woke wokeness or something so as with
everything he does he's
variable I do think uh it's a reason a
lot of people don't like him is this
political Evolution had he not spoken
about politics had he not tweeted things
had he not Twitter had he not gone down
to the southern border and shown videos
of people trying to get across the Rio
Grand I think he would be a lot you know
wouldn't wouldn't be a lightning rod
wouldn't have so many people but it's
part of who he is as he gets worked up
about things there's no one simple
answer where I can say is he a Democrat
Republican left right I think you have
to read the evolution that happens over
the past three years now that it's
fascinating I think a lot of the
response now and the way I see politics
is there's like this um
anti-institutional energy that takes
various forms and I feel like Elon has
been attacked by various institutions
and so he he has come across as kind of
anti-institutional right he hates the
mainstream media and he thinks he's
always been attacked and the great old
institutions and I do remind him that I
think I may be the poster boy for the
old online oldfashioned establishment
media having spent my time at Time
Magazine and uh CNN but he laughs about
that well he he gave you a personal
exemption
[Laughter]
Walter in the corner I'm letting
everybody go for the ride everybody gets
to I think he's fascinating as well as
controversial and I think it's useful to
just watch him and form your own
judgments
you know when I come out of Louisiana
they're either preachers or
storytellers and I had a mentor Tell Me
For Heaven's Sake be a Storyteller this
world's got too many
preachers hey YouTube glad you're
enjoying the podcast if you really like
it hit subscribe and then YouTube will
notify you every time we have a bang up
new guest thank
you